this video is sponsored by the book
summary service blink
[Music]
Lucius aeneas Seneca was commonly known
as just Seneca is recognized as one of
the primary forefathers of stoic
philosophy stoicism is a school of
thought that formed initially in Athens
Greece in 3rd century BC by an
individual named Zeno of City 'm and
despite the years of fluctuating
historic and cultural circumstances that
stoicism has endured since it retains a
uniquely high level of popularity still
to this day testifying for its potency
and potential value to provide some
brief basic background after being
founded in ancient Greece
stoicism was further formed and
popularized in ancient Rome and is most
commonly associated with individuals of
this time like Marcus Aurelius
Epictetus and of course Seneca the key
principles of the philosophy generally
include living in accordance with nature
devoting oneself to wisdom
virtue and Duty avoiding acting on
intense emotion embracing one's fate and
focusing more on the internal experience
of life as opposed to the external in
terms of Seneca specifically he was born
around 4 BC in Spain but lived most of
his life in Rome until he died there in
65 AD throughout his life he was a
statesman orator tragic writer
philosopher as well as a variety of
other things
Seneca lived the life of rather extreme
ups and downs as a result of his
particular relationship with various
aspects of the politics of Rome at the
time in a lot of ways he can be observed
to have struggled to follow what would
be considered his own stoic advice which
is perhaps worth noting however arguably
it does not devalue many of the ideas he
shared but rather perhaps a test to the
difficulty of them as aforementioned a
leading stoic principle is that we lack
a great deal of control over the
outcomes and happenings of our external
world and we can only really ultimately
choose if anything how we choose to
perceive the unfolding of it how we
frame our experience of the fate of
everything and the immovable qualities
of our condition one particular
condition that we are thrown and
subjected into that Seneca focused much
of his discourse on is time more
specifically how to handle our slippery
and transient experience of it Seneca
observed that we
tend to be frugal and prudent with many
aspects of our life we tend to hoard our
money and possessions and whatever else
we can see and get her hands on and yet
when it comes to time we rarely guard it
or evaluate carefully how well we save
and spend it he suggested that we often
give up a great deal of our time to
things and people that we wouldn't
consider to be worthy of giving anything
to if we slowed down and thought about
what we were doing and why men are
thrifty and guarding their private
property but as soon as it comes to
wasting time they are most extravagant
with the one commodity for which it's
respectable to be greedy wrote Seneca in
its essay and letter entitled on the
shortness of life time in Senecas mind
is to be viewed like any other commodity
of life and if anything to be viewed as
the most valuable one ultimately all we
have is our minds and our time and no
one ever knows how much time they have
inside their mind and once it's gone you
can't work for buy or fight for it back
this is fairly obvious and even cliche
to utter as a sentiment at this point
but despite its obvious Ness Seneca
observed then and it can certainly still
be observed now that most of us remain
incapable of living as if we seem to
continue to treat our time like it's
more or less infinite and more or less
inferior to the other objects of our
possessions unlike the majority of
possessions in life you can't see hold
or truly note I'm making it
incomprehensibly slippery and abstract
and because the present is so brief and
immaterial Seneca thought is why we
mostly struggle to properly perceive and
value it for Seneca to confront the
concept of time one must first fully
confront the conditions of their
relationship with its finitude and
accept their fate as an observer or sort
of passenger to it that you are slipping
in every moment towards the end of all
moments and at any moment it could all
be cut short and you can't do anything
about it
this although bleak is perhaps worth
often considering because the likely
fact is that if everyone who is going to
lose their life in the next couple years
knew they would mostly all of those
people would live differently and thus
we must live not as if we are one of the
ones who will live into late age but
rather one of the ones who might not
because only in such case can the
finitude of life begin to reveal itself
and only when the finitude of life
reveals itself can we live in a way the
might resemble how a finite life should
be lived of course the challenge of this
is no small feat the difference between
imagining life might end next week or in
a couple years is vastly different than
knowing and in fact will and to know and
manage this balance between now and
later is perhaps one of the greatest
human complications but Seneca like many
other great philosophers and
philosophies believe that we can and
must work to overcome our tendency to
look towards the future for solace and
rather better focus our perspective on
the present not only because the future
might not come but even if it does when
it arrives it'll likely just be another
moment to spend preparing and longing
for further future moments if we remain
stuck in such a constant preparatory
cycle it is inevitable wrote Seneca that
life will be not just very short but
very miserable for those who acquire by
great toil what they must keep by
greater toil they achieve what they want
laborious ly they possess what they have
achieved anxiously and meanwhile they
take no account of time that will never
more return new preoccupations take the
place of the old hope excites more hope
and ambition more ambition they do not
look for an end to their misery but
simply change the reason for it for
Seneca to hope to live for oneself
finally in the future is to wait until
it's properly too late rather to make
the most of time is to make the most of
today lay hold of today's task and you
will not need to depend so much upon
tomorrow's he wrote seneca believe that
one should spend their time fulfilling
their duties and responsibilities
enjoying any wealth or fortunes that
might come of them but not working for
the purpose of social status or material
success beyond one's minimal needs
because beyond mostly everything else he
argued for allocating as much time as
possible to leisure more specifically a
particular type of well focused leisure
in which one finds tranquility
introspection and stillness in
themselves because to be busily engaged
in doing nothing is not valuable
productivity and to spend one's free
time doing things that are of no real
personal value is not well used leisure
both are but clever ways of wasting time
the truly leisure person Seneca wrote is
one who is also conscious of his own
leisure
the most valuable use of leisure in his
mind is philosophy
time spent on intellectual reflections
in which one recognizes feels and
observes deeply the life that is being
sifted through each moment it seems that
in this the worthy esteem is in some
sense spending it on itself by
considering or at least pondering time
and how to best use it one is
paradoxically using it well Seneca
described the value of this sort of
reflection like that of securing the
fluidity of time at the bottom of a
glass sort of contain it properly in
order to see and possess it the study of
life and time helps us in his mind widen
or deepen the experience of the very
life and time we are studying allowing
us to fill our self with the wisdoms
wonders and connection points to the
long-gone or distant minds of people
that we need as our closest friends but
otherwise could never know or meet when
referring to the study of intellectual
matters Seneca wrote you really ought to
leave ground level and turn your mind's
eye to these studies in this mode of
life much that is worth studying awaits
you the love and practice of the virtues
forgetfulness of the passions knowledge
of how to live and die and deep repose
Seneca believed the wisdom to be
timeless and thus the primary thing
worth pursuing and investing in and
considering his words as some 2,000
years old and are still thought to have
value his argument here does appear to
hold some validity how much validity and
how much time they can hold time will
tell
in truth it's fair to argue that no
matter who you are and what philosophy
you share or follow no one truly knows
how to fully wrestle with the concept of
time and win and whether or not the use
of one's time is best served two
philosophical studies and contemplations
is perhaps true or perhaps not and
perhaps who's to say perhaps to know how
anyone can or should spend their time is
some amount conceded and to know why
anyone should do anything instead of
nothing or nothing instead of anything
isn't self-evident it perhaps like most
things comes down to the individual
level what one beams valuable for
themselves and more importantly how well
they act on what they deem valuable for
themselves wasted time or well spent
time is all the same when viewed from a
sufficient distance outside of it and it
is only to those in it during it that
can examine consider and determine the
best way they wish to balance and claim
it and all anyone can ever do is try
their best there's clear value in now
and thus there's clear value in the now
is yet to come
value that we must consider when
treating the now we are in but not so
much so that there is none left in
either which appears to leave us with
some level of cognitive dissonance when
dealing with time the balancing act of
now and later is perhaps nearly an
impossible feat but perhaps it is only
in the examination of time that we get
to consider such a problem and it is
perhaps only in the consideration of
such a problem that we can feel the
wonder that is the blender of human
consciousness a sense of confusion
wrapped in intrigue curiosity and desire
to resolve which is improper full-circle
fashion with Seneca believed to be the
best use of time
ultimately Seneca and his stoic
affiliates helped serve as a bridge into
this realm of thought and wisdom to help
illuminate times form so we can better
see it as we see any other object
commodity or feature of existence to
create the internal fortitude to fight
the external indifference of the
universe and the internal solace to be
ok when we lose this video was sponsored
by blinka stay if you aren't familiar
blink astiz a book summary service that
condenses complete books down to around
15 minutes summaries making it easy to
understand the overviews and essential
takeaways in an efficient amount of time
covering thousands of non-fiction books
in an array of subjects like philosophy
science psychology health and much more
Glinka has a diverse range of titles for
just about anyone if you're interested
in philosophy and stoicism specifically
Linkous has great titles including
letters from a stoic by Seneca
meditations by Marcus Aurelius the
obstacle is the way by ryan holiday as
well as others with comprehensive
overviews plinkus not only makes it easy
to understand the main ideas of books
but perhaps most valuable it can help
you more efficiently select new books
and authors by helping you better and
more quickly determine whether or not
you are interested without necessarily
having to read the full versions first
to find out for obvious reasons this
could be very helpful for more effective
reading and learning habits especially
with the value of time being so high the
first 100 people to use the link in the
description will receive one free week
of unlimited access as well as 25% off a
full membership the free 7-day trial
could be cancelled at any time within
the trial period again if you're
interested please visit blinkers comm
slash pursuit of wonder or click the
link in the description thanks so much
for watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]